.
>>> A stunning visit inside
Ukraine.
Here's Vladimir Putin in the
donbas region for the first time
since rash invaded he touted the
Russian controlled city of
mariupol and surveyed
reconstruction programs after
the damage inflicted by his
military.
His visit comes days after the
international criminal court
issued a warrant for his arrest
for his role in an alleged
scheme to deport thousands of
Ukrainian children to Russia.
For more let's bring in CNN
military analyst lieutenant
general mark hurt ling.
Putin spent Saturday touring the
streets he helped destroy in a
country still deeply entrenched
in war.
What kind of message does that
send both to his troops and the
Ukrainians?
>> He's trying to send a
message Paula but have
difficulties as you see in the
pictures he was going through
the one apartment building
rebuilt sort of as a village, I
don't use that loosely in the
city of mariupol.
As you just said, that city was
utterly devastated by his
shelling of civilian apartments
and hospitals and schools and
now he's going back to take a
look around, and it's a photo
opt as you see him in this film
in the middle of an apartment
building he's trying to relocate
some Ukrainian civilians, it's
sending a signal because it's
still very far to the west
behind enemy lines.
It's in the province -- the
Russians have control of that
province right now.
But I think we'll see in the
coming months that that will be
a targeted area for the
Ukrainian counter offensive to
take back their sovereign
territory.
>> Tomorrow Chinese president XI
is traveling to Moscow to meet
with Putin, U.S. Furthers warn
any proposal that comes out
these talk would say likely
favor Russians do you think
China could change the dynamics
of this war.
>> I do not, Paula, the draft
peace proposal the Chinese
already petitioned is all behind
the Russian attempts at gaining
a cease fire, a freeze on the
territory, which would create
another frozen conflict.
There are currently five frozen
conflicts within Europe Russia
created and I don't believe that
certainly president zelenskyy or
the Ukrainian people are going
to abide by any kind of proposal
that China gives in coordination
with Russia.
And what's interesting though,
too, as you said, president XI
is going to Moscow, he'll be
shaking hands with the
president, president Putin, few
days after Putin was named by
The Hague as a war criminal and
a warrant issued for his arrest.
I don't think that's good optics
at all for the Chinese
president.
>> Shifting gear as bit,
tomorrow is the 20th anniversary
of the U.S. Invasion of Iraq,
you for the only served but
commanded army forces throughout
that war.
What lessons have we learned in
the years since 2003
>> It's great it's sort of the
same lesson that is Ukrainian is
learning truthfully.
And not Denaro grading the
soldiers I fought with who did
masterfully in Iraq but the
mission was convoluted and
complex, there's a lot of people
reflecting on that 20's years
later and saying what was our
strategy?
What were we attempting to do?
The intelligence was flawed
going into Iraq and there
wasn't a very good end state
other than to depose adam
hussein as a dictator, the
biggest lesson I think a lot of
people -- if they haven't
learned they should, is don't go
to war unless you have a very
good strategy for what you're
attempting to do and you have a
very good preliminary end state
for what you want to accomplish.
Neither one of things were done
in Iraq, and just like the
Russians, also, I would harken
back I was the war planner in
the Pentagon when that war was
planned.
And actually stood up and said,
there are not enough forces for
this kind of operation and our
end state, objectives are not
very clear.
Truthfully, I think we learned a
lot from that.